>> Juan: VOTERS LOOKING TO
UNSEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2020
NOT GOING TO BE HAPPY WITH
MARK CUBAN.
THE BILLIONAIRE SAYING THE
CURRENT FIELD OF DEMOCRATIC
CONTENDERS DON'T STAND A CHANCE.
CUBAN ALSO NOT RULING OUT A
PRESIDENTIAL RUN OF HIS OWN AS
AN INDEPENDENT.
WATCH.
>> I'VE SAID IT MANY TIMES.
IT WOULD TAKE THE PERFECT STORM
FOR ME TO DO IT, SO THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT COULD OPEN THE
DOOR BUT I'M NOT PROJECTING OR
PREDICTING IT RIGHT NOW.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE HAS THE BEST
CHANCE?
>> NOBODY RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
FIELD, IT'S ALL POLITICIANS.
POLITICIANS ARE THE LEAST
TRUSTED OF EVERY PROFESSION.
SO YOU KNOW, IT'S TOO EARLY TO
TELL.
>> Juan: SHANNON, HE MAY BE
RIGHT.
HE'S A REALITY TV STAR AND HE IS
SAYING YOU NEED SOMEBODY WITH
THAT KIND OF PROFILE TO DEFEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Shannon: THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
SHADES OF ROSS PEROT, FREAK OUT
TIME, LIKE WHEN HOWARD SCHULTZ
TALKS ABOUT IT FOR ANY OF THESE
OTHER INDEPENDENT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NAME RECOGNITION AND MONEY
AND CONNECTIONS.
THEY HAVE THE IDEA THAT THEY
COULD MOVE FORWARD.
YOU THINK ABOUT CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF BUSH 41 NOT HAVING
A SECOND TERM, SOMEONE LIKE
MARK CUBAN MAKES A DEMOCRATS
VERY NERVOUS BECAUSE OF WHAT HE
BRINGS TO THE TABLE.
>> Juan: MORE SO THAN HOWARD
SCHULTZ.
>> Shannon: HE'S DONE THE
REALITY TV THING, HE HAS MIXED
IT UP WITH TRUMPET FLOOR AND I
COULD SEE THEM GOING TOE-TO-TOE
AND BOTH OF THEM ENJOYING IT.
>> Juan: JESSE, YOU GET DOWN
TO THE BASICS AND I SEE THIS
CAMPAIGN IS MARK CUBAN SAYING
HEY, THAT'S A BIG MILLIONAIRE.
I'M A REAL BILLIONAIRE.
VOTE FOR ME.
>> Jesse: I TEASED HIM AND I
SAID YOU'RE JEALOUS THAT ANOTHER
BILLIONAIRE CELEBRITY RAN FOR
PRESIDENT AND WON.
HE SAID I'M NOT JEALOUS.
TRUMP IS NOT A BILLIONAIRE.
[LAUGHTER]
I TOLD HIM WE WERE DURING THE
SEGMENT AND HE SAID TELL GREG I
WILL HAVE THE CRAMPS PLAY AT THE
INAUGURATION.
>> Greg: HE'S GOT MY VOTE.
HE IS A CRAMPS FAN, WHICH IS
AMAZING.
>> Jesse: I LIKE HIM.
I'M NOT A MAVERICKS FAN BUT I
LIKE THAT HE SPEAKS HIS MIND AND
THE ONLY THING IS I THINK HE'S
FLOATING THIS OUT THERE BECAUSE
HE'S TRYING TO BOOST HIS BRAND A
LITTLE BIT AND GET HIS NAME IN
THE NEWS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IF HE
DOES RUN, WHO DOES HE TAKE VOTES
AWAY FROM?
I RAN HIS PLATFORM POSITIONS
THROUGH THE MATRIX AND WE FOUND
HE'S A TALLER, BETTER LOOKING
MIKE BLOOMBERG WITH A HINT OF
LIBERTARIAN RON PAUL AND A
SPLASH OF ACLU.
BOTTOM LINE, HE'S NOT GOING TO
RUN SO IT DOESN'T MATTER.
HE DID SEE SOMETHING ELSE
INTERESTING.
SO FAR THE DEMOCRAT PROPOSALS
HAVE BEEN ALL HEADLINE PORN.
I DON'T THINK WHAT THEY BELIEVE
THEY ARE PROPOSING IS PASSABLE.
IT'S TRUE.
YOU THING ABOUT GUN GRABBING AND
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE, GREEN NEW
DEAL.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO GET PAST.
THEY PUT THE GREEN NEW DEAL UP
TO A VOTE IN THE SENATE IN EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT ABSTAINED.
>> Juan: DANA, HE DID SAY NICE
THINGS ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
HE SAID BIDEN IS A SMART GUY AND
HE COULD DO A GOOD JOB.
>> Dana: HE USES THE WORD
CHARISMA.
THERE'S 24 CANDIDATES NOW YOU
LOOK AT THEIR SOUND BITES AND
WHO GRABBED EAR?
HERE IN THE CAR, NOT EVERYBODY
IS GLUED TO THEIR TELEVISION,
ALTHOUGH THANK YOU FOR WATCHING.
IT'S THE CHARISMA.
WHO MAKES YOU WANT TO LISTEN?
DO YOU LISTEN TO MARK CUBAN?
HE CALLS IN, DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
IN THE STUDIO, HE CALLS AND,
LIKE TRUMP.
HOWARD SCHULTZ CAN'T CALL IN.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN FOR
HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE IS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Jesse: WHEN YOU ARE HOT,
THEY TAKE YOU ON THE PHONE.
>> Dana: REMEMBER WHEN --
NEVER MIND.
WHEN "THE FIVE" FIRST STARTED,
THERE WAS SOMEONE WHO CALLED
INTO THE SHOW BUT THEY WERE
UPSTAIRS.
>> Greg: ES.
IT WAS NOT BILL O'REILLY.
>> Dana: WE REALIZED HE WAS
UPSTAIRS.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT CUBAN IS SAYING IS WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN SENT HERE FOR THE LAST
COUPLE MONTHS.
>> Greg: WHAT IS MISSING IS
THE NONPOLITICAL PERSON.
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T TALK LIKE A
POLITICIAN.
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE THEIR
TRUMP.
THE THING IS INSTEAD THEY HAVE A
22-HEADED, 24-HEADED
JACK-IN-THE-BOX.
THEY ALL LOOK THE SAME.
IN THE OLD DAYS WE USED TO SAY
WHILE -- WOW IT'S AN IMPRESSIVE
FIELD, LOOK AT ALL THESE PEOPLEB
FIELD, LOOK AT ALL THESE PEOPLET
NOW WE GO THERE'S WAY TOO MANY.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
IT'S A BUSLOAD OF TALKING HEADS.
I DON'T GET IT.
THE WEIRD THING IS, THAT USED TO
BE GOOD.
NOW IT'S GOOD IS TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT A POLITICIAN
WHO IS LOUD WHO DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE A POLITICIAN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BIDEN, THAT'S
ALL YOU SEE IS POLITICIAN, AND
IT FEELS LIKE WHEN HE'S TALKING
YOU'RE WATCHING A GUY ON
CRUTCHES MAKING HIS WAY DOWN A
STAIRCASE.
AT ANY MOMENT, HE'S GOING TO
COLLAPSE AND IT'S GOING TO BE
UGLY.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE LIKE TRUMP WHO
CAN TALK FOR HOURS ABOUT
SLIPPERY STAGES.
MY POINT IS THIS.
DO THE DEMOCRATS GO FOR THAT
COMFORTABLE SWEATER AND BIDEN
WHO FEELS LIKE SOMETHING THAT
YOU ARE USED TO OR DO YOU GO FOR
THE JUMPSUIT THAT EVEL KNIEVEL
WEARS WHEN HE WENT INTO THE
SNAKE RIVER CANYON?
>> Juan: YOU KNOW TYPICALLY
POLITICS RUNS IN CYCLES AND I
THINK AFTER TRUMP, THERE MAY BE
A DESIRE FOR SOME SWEATERS AND
STABILITY.
>> Greg: BUT REMEMBER, STABLE
POLITICIANS ARE EVERY BIT AS
DANGEROUS AS ANYBODY ELSE.
THEY START WARS AND THEY DO
STUPID THINGS.
WE HAVE AN UNBREAKABLE PRESIDENT
WHO MIGHT BE THE MOST PEACEFUL
PRESIDENT WE'VE HAD.
>> Jesse: SOME PEOPLE CALL HIM
A VERY STABLE GENIUS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I WILL SAY THEY ARE
BOTH REALITY STAR SO I GUESS
THAT'S A MOMENT AND MAYOR IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
>> Jesse: MAY BE SNOOKIE IS
GOING TO RUN.